بدائل [موسيقى] أجنبية
[موسيقى]
وكل شيء على ما يرام
خاصة في منزلنا،
الجميع ينامون خارج المنازل
ولكن يمكنني أن أرى
أنه تم
تنسيقها بشكل جيد للغاية على
المستوى الوطني، عندما وصلنا
كانوا يعاملوننا بشكل جيد للغاية  لقد دعمونا
بالنقل بالشاحنات، لقد
سمحوا لنا بالمساعدة، لقد ساعدونا في
المساعدة، نعم ولديهم فرقهم في
الموقع وفي اليوم الأول كان هناك الكثير من
الناس في الشارع الآن الجميع لديه
الخيام، لذا لديهم طعام
ولديهم ماء  لذلك على الأقل لديهم ما
يلزم لذلك أعتقد أنني أستطيع أن أهنئ
الحكومة الأمريكية التي كنت
أعمل فيها في الحكومة، ما هي
أسوأ قرية قمت بزيارتها
هذه الأيام وهذه أي قرية هذه هذه نعم نعم وماذا
تفعل كل يوم أين
هم  لقد بقيت في الليل جيدًا، لقد أتينا مكتفين
ذاتيًا، لذلك نأتي
بخيامنا، حسنًا، طعامنا ومياهنا،
لا نريد الإزعاج، لقد جئنا للمساعدة، لذلك
لا نريد أن نحصل على المساعدة،
الشيء الوحيد الذي لا يمكننا إحضاره، لذلك نحن  لقد قمنا بإعداد
معسكر قاعدتنا حسنًا، هذا فقط داخل
معسكر قاعدة فريق الإنقاذ المغربي نحن
ونعمل معًا هل يطلبون منا
المساعدة أو أو نقدم المساعدة ونعمل
معًا نذهب معًا للقيام
بمهامنا وكيف  هل تلعب لعدة أيام
وتخطط للبقاء هنا في المنطقة،
ولن نبقى كثيرًا لأن
تخصصنا هو البحث والإنقاذ والآن
لا يوجد، أعني أنه لا يوجد لقد
قاموا بعمل جيد جدًا هنا
لأنهم يعرفون ذلك طوال حياتهم
وهم ليسوا على قيد الحياة، وقد تم
عرض الأفلام عليهم، ولديهم رقابة صارمة للغاية، لذا أصبح
السكان هادئين الآن، لكنهم
ربما يحتاجون إلى المساعدة لاستعادة
حياتهم الطبيعية الآن وهم
أجانب